as the jury in the trial of kyle
rittenhouse deliberated and prepared to
issue a verdict in keeping with our
system of law black lives matter members
decided to put their finger on the
scales of justice if the jurors refused
to sacrifice the obviously innocent
teenager to the mob
[Music]
[Music]
if kenosha don't get it shut it down so
this is about kyle rittenhouse this is
outside the cal rittenhouse trial but
then they start referencing jacob blake
seven shots in the back seven shots in
the back which uh he deserved he
deserved more than that frankly and the
cops i think were lenient with with
jacob blake
but what does this have to do with that
we're talking about a completely
separate incident i suppose the only
thing that has to do with it is that
kyle rittenhouse was present at the
riots that began after the jacob blake
arrest i'm glad you liked that clip
now please ring the bell
please subscribe
leave me a comment and if youtube is not
totally your thing and you're not
getting notifications or whatever head
on over to apple podcast spotify stitch
or google play wherever you get your
podcasts that's going to be the more
reliable option to make sure you never
miss an episode we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you